[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 184 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am mark and today I'm here with Mark
hey Mark hey Mark how are ya I have a
cold so I'm at home and my house is
flowing pop but that's none of that I'm
doing well how are you doing you know I
like your positive attitude which is off
yeah thanks that sound that sounds bad
it's fine it's fine everything will be
fine
eventually it all works out after a
while but we have a great interview
today Debbie and I did an interview with
informatica with Bill Creek balm senior
director of product management for cloud
big data and analytic ecosystems at
informatica whoo that is a long title I
hope when they have a title that long
but we talked all about hybrid cloud
with big data and analytics migrations
from prime to cloud with big data
analytics all sorts of good stuff around
essentially big data analytics that
sounds pretty exciting and I think that
if you tried hard enough you could
probably just insert more Google
products into your title yeah I think so
master of a gonna say and kubernetes and
dataflow and bigquery and also
consultant on and you could just keep
going they not have to learn a lot more
products that I currently know and that
sounds hard and I don't feel like doing
that well in order to test your
knowledge there I have a great question
of the week for you which talks a little
bit about App Engine and using custom
domains but before we even get an
assassin we should talk about our cool
things of the week
we absolutely should so first of all let
me say a Ledge congratulations to
Chronicle if you're not familiar with
Chronicle they are the security moonshot
company when inside Google that deal
with all kinds of interesting security
stuff you may have heard the episode we
did previously 1:35 talking about that
one of their things which is virus
turtle which is actually a free scanner
for files for malware and viruses can
also be used by companies it's very very
cool and she's one of the things they do
in the security space but pretty excited
to have them on board with Google cloud
to help enhance the security features we
have with Google cloud and make all the
security things better for all our
customers yeah I mean it sounds awesome
and I think that it's not as though
people aren't concerned about security
and you know we talk a lot about
encryption and all the kind of different
infrastructure level security offerings
that Google cloud has by default but for
a larger company is like you need more
right you need virus protection email
infection all those things so I think
that then joining Google cloud will
really open up some real cool
opportunities for people who use the
cloud one of the cool things that I was
actually just recently reading is that
we are opening a new undersea cable
absolute it's right around though the
west coast of Africa so it goes all the
way from Europe all the way down to the
bottom of Africa and case you weren't
aware Africa is a very big continent so
that's gonna be a big cable I just think
it's fascinating when I joined Google
there were a lot of people making jokes
about the undersea cables and the shark
proofing which apparently is a real
thing right and for anyone who hasn't
heard of it you know we had these big
undersea cables that is the thing around
the clear thing and a common problem
apparently with those cables is that
sharks like to eat them which I can't
relate to I have today I believe it
actually has something to do with the
electronics going through it and it sets
up their sensors and like they like
really like I don't know exactly but oh
I should do some research on that sounds
really cool yeah but for the people who
are trying to get internet through those
wires it turns out sharks are kind of a
pain yeah generally speaking people
chewing through your cables is a bad
thing anyway I think it's really awesome
and it just fascinates me that we're
just building these huge pipelines to
just kind of add additional connectivity
for a lot of different areas so I'm
really excited to see this one come
online the next two years
yeah absolutely
and shout out to all their listeners in
Africa hopefully this works out very
well for you alright cool so I think I
have something else as well oh yes I
would be remiss if I didn't mention
kubernetes at least once in a podcast so
this is a little bit ago but I don't
think it's been mentioned so far
kubernetes 115 congratulations to the
team on that release I'm pretty excited
about this this is a lot of
extensibility around Cora Crippen Eddy's
API is including custom resource
definitions and a lot of new features
for custom resource definitions which is
an area in which I work in a lot so it's
very excited about that
as well as cluster or lifecycle
stability and usability improvements
container storage functionality and lots
of other good things there as well so if
you want to dig more into that there's
actually a really good article that will
link to as well talking about the future
of customer resource definitions which
they're calling structural schemas
that's a lot of alliteration yeah when
they go into that a lot deeper and I'm
pretty excited about it looks like it's
gonna be really really handy for those
people who write controllers and
operators you know there's a little lot
of obviously a lot of recent news around
kubernetes and then somewhat related is
sto of course which I think just
relaunched two or 1.12 not recently I
should know that but I think it's super
cool to see all these updates I'm seeing
a lot of stuff on the internet about
people being scared about kubernetes
kind of adding too many features into
that so I'm really interested to see how
the community is really driving a lot of
the kind of upgrades and different
things that go into each kubernetes
release yeah I think you know and it's
just year 1.2 I check it out for you
this could be a whole episode in and of
itself you know I think there's two
things to that I think there's a lot of
stuff that you can just do with
kubernetes like services and deployments
and that's it like you could just get
started with that you know you can get
running but I think all the extension
mechanisms mean that people can build
simpler layers even or highly
opinionated layers going forward as well
to make things easier for very specific
workloads so I think there's there's a
two-pronged approach there but yeah that
could almost be a turn episode that
sounds like it might be a good episode
actually yeah actually now that you
mention it why don't we do that episode
we should do that episode
all right well make a note and do that
cool but let's finish this one first yes
I have one more cool thing of the week
which is now that stack driver profiler
is now generally available who fancy
this was a really cool tool that it was
I think wasn't beta for quite a while
but it actually lets you kind of look at
production code that's executing and
then kind of see how it's performing
as it traces through like as different
functions are being called and you kind
of gives you this cool little visual
stack of where your time is being spent
so for a lot of the people who use
stackdriver and a lot of people who
actually I should say who are using
production code on GCP stackdriver has
been a really awesome tool because it
lets you do live code debugging and
fixing in production mmm which is super
impressive but probably not fixing but
actual like observation and seeing like
oh well you know sometimes in dev you
just can't reproduce that problem yeah
so being able to reproduce it in
production and then having a really
clear visual graph of like where those
slowdowns are and where the problem
might be I think that's super awesome
and so now that it's GA I think
hopefully a lot more people will be more
comfortable trying it out yeah that
sounds really great fantastic well I
tell you what why don't we get stuck
into the interview that Gaby and I did
with Bill from informatica and we can
hear all about big data and analytics
and all sorts of other fun things cool
excited to hear it
[Music]
so I'm very happy today to have Bill
Creek bomb here senior director product
management cloud and big data ecosystems
from informatica oh my god that's a lot
bill how are you doing today I'm doing
great
thanks mark thank you so much for
joining us today before we get stuck
into some big data things and talking a
little bit of informatica as well that
is a really big product title so and who
are you what do you do what was listed
all about so I have the privilege of
working with the cloud big data
analytics ecosystems are informatica and
a lot of our customers would think
especially in a context of Google that
means we really focus on connectivity to
bigquery and Google Cloud Storage but we
actually have a much broader charter I'm
really focused on making sure that all
of our products take the most advantage
of the strengths of the Google cloud
platform you know so for example we have
a big data management product that
allows customers to visually build and
manage Big Data jobs that integrate with
all our governance tools and what not an
option that we have through the
partnership with Google is we allow the
customers to design and informatica and
push the job down to data procs so it
actually runs as a pushdown job there we
can do similar capabilities with
bigquery more recently we have really
done a lot of partnership with Google to
create value added solutions for our
Comment customers and its far more than
just connectivity now we're really
thinking about you know broad use cases
you know customer 360 type use cases
marketing use cases it's very excited so
you said a little words that I'm gonna
guess relate to Big Data and stuff but
why don't we have start at a high level
like so what is informatica actually do
so you know informatica provides import
photo of data management products you
know all of our products are very
metadata aware and you know the benefit
there is by having a complete solution
that focuses on you know integration
governance security data quality and
discoverability you know you have that
completely integrated solution that
allows you to you know move quickly move
safely deal with you know strict
regulations with confidence and at the
same time deliver business value right I
mean everyone talks about the
democratization of data this is how you
do it yeah
you're missing any one of those pieces
then you're starting to worry you open
yourselves up to risk and then that's
when you start to hold the data back and
so I think with our platform you know we
really allow business users to get a
hold of the data awesome
so what's like a really great example of
someone using informatica and Google
cloud together that the people might
like what would be a canonical example
of that there's a couple of really good
examples yeah I think a lot of what I've
been really excited to see recently is
you know customers that you try to build
like a customer 360 type you know
analytical solutions and you know they
started on Prime they started using
Hadoop and that was really a lot of the
promise of you know the beginning of the
big Native movement but the operational
costs are just so extreme and but now
they're working with you know Google and
bigquery in particular and there just
seems so much tremendous opportunity to
move those very expensive workloads
on-prem into the cloud they're saving a
ton of money but more importantly
they're seeing new opportunities that
technology is opening doors to new use
cases and I think that's my favorite
part is like customers begin the journey
is like oh it's gonna be cheaper for me
to run it at the cloud and then they
pause I think like Oh a living you mean
I can do it completely different and
faster and still do it cheaper
definitely you start to see the
creativity of our customers in our
industry at large really take flight so
if I'm a ticket then it's more like for
one I got it you were able to facilitate
ETL processing for customers let's say
you let them build their own pipelines
apparently and beyond that how the
customers approached you you started
some already have an old set up idea
from the beginning of big data but how
usually like a new company comes to you
to have no big data at all they want to
start doing it how does approach happens
well you know it definitely depends on
where that particular customer is in
their what's called the modernization
journey right but what we've been really
excited to see is that when our
customers use you know our complete
portfolio not just our integration
products but the complete portfolio
especially with
you know our metadata driving cattle
like it please because they start much
more from a use case perspective they
start from a business object perspective
you know because first of all you know
you gotta find the right data right you
might have like a sales operation use
kiss right and you're working with sales
ops you want to modernize you know let's
say a marketing lead campaign initiative
right well to start I gotta go find good
marketing lead data and so if I have a
catalog that has you know scan my
enterprise I could type in you know the
Google for the enterprise right you know
I'll show me all my marketing lead data
and you might get back twenty thirty
maybe fifty different data assets at
that point okay I'm overwhelmed as a
business user so did I just picked the
one at the top do I randomly pick how do
I choose
and what's really beneficial is that
when you have that data catalog
capability with a higher order value
right whose machine learning to identify
Business Objects
you know low KPI hi you can start to
make some really intelligent decisions
and yeah because now I can determine
this says marketing lead does I have all
the elements that's required for a
complete marketing the object so that's
kinda like step one and step two is do I
know where that data came from and do I
know if it's being used downstream of by
a different application so for example
if I see a market and late object and I
see that that object is being populated
by you know Marketo and Salesforce
sources right those were pretty reliable
industry sources and I see it being
consumed by ten downstream applications
that says well this is actually being
used by the business I can safely assume
that this object is valuable and trusted
whereas if I compare it with another
object that has no downstream
consumption I can make some you know
informed decisions on which data to
begin using so the point is is by
combining data discovery with data
integration you can make you know much
better decisions about what dated
integrate and then go straight into the
provisioning process to bigquery I
usually see people saying agreed that
your business value relies on the
quality of data that you have it doesn't
matter how much money I'm bringing if
you're not curating your data properly
you're gonna have some troubles
especially if you wanna more than
do data analytics do machine learning
you need to relying on your source and
do you encounter a lot of people having
problems with like data that's not
normalized data that's not like
duplicated records let's say you know do
you have that many issues and how do you
help those customers solve this kind of
issues too or not absolutely I've been
in the analytic space for better part of
the past decade and I've seen so many
analytics initiatives fail after such
great intentions because of bad quality
it has nothing to do with the analytics
itself has to do it bad raw material
right and the quality of data comes from
a couple of different scenarios number
one is like is it safe for me to access
right if I can't safely access the data
there's no point right at that point
quality doesn't matter so you know
having a solution that you know masks
data or adheres to role based access
controls you know number one I mean that
allows a business user to safely use the
data right and we all talk about
enabling the citizen X rights as
integrators as an application developer
so as an analyst we want those business
users to safely acquire them okay so
once your platform has allowed them to
safely acquire the data what is the
quality right and quality is
completeness of data right you know if
I've got a data set that's got a bunch
of null values that's gonna have limited
utility for me right and being able to
really profile your data set gives me an
understanding of the quality of data but
beyond that you know now we get into
chemical higher order of data quality
and so let's continue our marketing late
example you know if I you know got a
table what's really good marketing lead
object definitions and part of that is
email addresses phone numbers and zip
codes yet 60% of my email addresses are
malformed and my zip codes only have
three digits yeah the structure might
look fantastic but the actual data's
gonna be useless for me right and you
don't want to throw it away you know do
you have the ability to recover from it
and you know get quality data and if not
you know can we safely exclude the data
so it's absolutely essential because at
the end of the day analytics comes down
to do you trust the output and the
higher the quality input
the better trusty house you know with to
go analytic given that we are the Google
cloud platform podcast this so sounds
really great but like in application
like what tools and products were using
here on Google cloud to help facilitate
this sort of pipeline the our customers
is a combination of both of our
company's products right yep and so you
know from informatica side they're using
our intelligent cloud services they're
using our kind of price data catalog big
data management and sometimes secured
source which is one of our governance
tools and then on the Google cloud
platform side you know Google bigquery I
mean I'm telling you guys I am seeing so
much traffic flow through to bigquery
and the adoption is fantastic and I'm
seeing you know like huge curves up into
the right in adoption and usage but to
really complement bigquery there's a lot
of usage of Google Cloud Storage that
makes a lot of sense I mean you know
behind the covers we use a lot of them
in tandem to lit drive performance of
bulk loading we also see a lot of
interoperation with Google Analytics and
we're starting to see a much bigger
uptake of technologies like pub/sub as
part of these workflows and already
talked about data proc earlier so what I
think that I think about a great deal
and my entire team thinks about is how
can we best provide our customers with
the strengths of bigquery and the entire
go platform a surfaced through the
informatica products right because I
want to give them easy access to that's
what informatics brings to the table
right we're doing yeah easy access
visual design environments governance
lineage metadata management etc but I
don't want to provide coverage that's
just like vanilla access I want our
customers to take the most advantage of
why they picked Google cloud in the
first place yes do you have customers
that are like hey I've already got a
Google cloud project and I've got a
bunch of stuff in Google Cloud storage
and they come to you and they're like
we're already doing stuff how do we
integrate or do you find it's coming
from the other way where like you've got
customers for informatica and they're
like oh actually now we want to push
this down into Google Cloud in some way
shape or form I gotta tell you mark
sometimes I feel like it's coming from
top bottom left and right
Oh different combinations but in all
seriousness I mean we really focus on
the hybrid Enterprise right and there's
just crazy momentum to the clock right I
mean heck I've been talking about it for
ever since the club was born right but
it is just happening with just fierce
velocity but no matter that velocity
large enterprises are still gonna have a
presence on Prem and we have to treat
that hybrid nature of unprimed multi
Club as first-class service right we all
do you know so a lot of times in our
customers will you know I hate to speak
in generalities but you know from
anecdote you know engagements in
evidence a lot of our customers will
start with I need to modernize Mike
legis warehouse and I want to get into
bigquery great cost performance benefits
great technology and they start off with
really just more of a cost savings right
they might get rid of their physical
infrastructure shift the operational low
to Google but the reality is that
halfway through that journey that light
that PIFAN II happens they start to see
much more than value add of what can be
done you know for example I was engaging
a large customer the joint customer
earlier in the year and their initial
goal was just to modernize their
warehouse with bigquery we started down
that path and it was going really well
and actually during a joint engagement
where I was actually co-presenting with
somebody from Google to this particular
customer the light went on and they're
gonna quit moving can I replace my
Hadoop environment on Prem with bigquery
and actually unify all my data you
should see the grins it was like this
collective room of lights going on about
what was possible the art of the
possible
you know so back to your point mark me
too you know coming from like you know
from existing scenarios or new scenarios
a lot of times it'll come with a new
initiative but then all of a sudden
they'll kind of blossom into multiple
initiatives happening at once so I'm
glad you brought up on Prem because I
wanted to ask you about like that data
migration story how are you seeing
customers taking their data and bringing
it from saying on Prem environment and
bringing it into the cloud I mean that
seems like a big job in and of itself
you know it is a big job in that itself
and you know there are you know
technical nuances that need to be
considered right yeah the one that I run
into most often
data types right but you know why I see
a lot of customers start with is just
like again they see dollar signs in the
opportunity for immediate cost savings
and that's absolutely correct I mean
there can be a tremendous and fast ROI
by moving from a legacy warehouse into
bigquery and what that means is that you
know customers oftentimes starting with
just like a lifted shift I just want to
take what's there move into bigquery and
be done right and it's true the customer
can realize some quick savings that way
but so much is lost and if you're gonna
go through this effort and let's be
honest this is an effort no matter how
much Austin tooling both of our
companies bring to the table it's still
an effort customers then don't take this
you know inflection point to think about
the future I think are missing a great
deal of opportunity right I think the
obvious example is you know classic
warehouse models are you know heavily
normalized right which made a lot of
sense for you know the classic warehouse
right based on old technologies store
jewel-tone tube and whatnot but we all
know that when you moved a bit query
it's like no no no no but seriously
normalize this really take advantage of
the power but it's such a complete shift
for you know DBAs and people have been
doing this for 25 30 years right and you
know for those that just simply do it
lift and shift for that immediate cost
savings I think they're really missing a
great opportunity and so a lot of times
we'll start off with a lift and shift to
get immediate success but then it
immediately moves into an evolution once
you're in bigquery to start taking
advantage of the data structures and
technologies in there so it's not an
either/or but it's a closely synchronous
and if you will you know if we go lift
and shift immediately into evolution and
that's where I think we see a lot of
benefits gained I remember when there
started working with a bit of big data
I'm not that versed let's say but the
fact of being able to use bigquery like
just put my data there and if you're out
indexes if you go out how many server is
gonna say crisping up a query that
probably makes your product more
versatile taking advantage of this kind
of thing
Knology and you said like this mind
shift for all time old-school DBAs some
has growing pains does that happen to
you too
it certainly does you know and I think
you know especially customers that have
been working with Tim from Attica for
twenty twenty-five years there's a
familiarity with the you know common
patterns right yeah but sometimes those
common patterns don't translate well
into the clouds there's a learning curve
and I think one of the thing is that
informatica is able to bring to the
table is that we help flat net learning
curve we can help take advantage of the
unique capabilities at the club faster
because you know from our customers
perspective they're still working with
this familiar toolset and yes the
technology behind that we're connecting
to differs but we're able to kind of
abstract it so we're able to get some
really fast adoption but once you get
that fast adoption remember you know a
few moments ago was talking about we
also want to make sure that the
customers can truly take advantage of
the characteristics of Google cloud
platform and query it so for example
maybe we talked about ETL earlier but
let's talk about alt you know extract
load transform we want to seriously take
advantage of that kind of capability in
a bit queries so using our you know
intelligent cloud services to actually
load data into bigquery and then process
the transformation inside bigquery we're
able to actually push down the entire
job into bigquery so that we're using
the bigquery engine to do all the
transformations and that's got a couple
of benefits number one you just talked
about you know it's a Service Catalog
environment with tremendous compute
power that you're able to spin up on to
Mia that means informatica is able to
take advantage of that and so we're able
to deliver you know a crazy amount of
performance with ease and our common
customers are benefiting greatly from
that fantastic
I'm kind of curious as well to obviously
you've worked with a variety of people
who do these sort of big data and
analytics platforms if you could like
tell anyone who works in like big dairy
analytics like one thing that they
should all be doing or like one mistake
they should potentially not make that's
broadly generalized like what would you
what would you suggest is like maybe
like the best practice you would love to
get out into their Oh mark that's such a
loaded question
that's why I asked it I have like 10 not
one okay yeah we can be able to come I
got some time yeah I think gotta
probably boil it down into three very
distinct recommendations
number one is you got to take stock of
what you've got I think companies are
completely surprised by the amount of
data assets that they have an every nook
and cranny of the enterprise and you
know you really want take a good
inventory of what you have determine
what's important and prioritizing
cataracts that that's not one but maybe
most importantly you need to set goals
and I know that sounds basic and it
sounds obvious but more often than not
I'm not seeing clear goal set so hey we
have no idea when we ever finished
because we don't know where we're headed
and when we do get there was it
successful
was it not we don't know and by setting
goals you set focus you said come like
your guiding star that everyone aligns
it marches towards which then leads them
to the third one and that is you got to
develop a team and again it seems
obvious but maybe not in the way that
you're thinking about it I would
recommend companies to format my Gration
you know SWAT team and this is the team
that is well versed both in the
technology and the business goals
because they need to be the leaders
right because they're gonna need good
people to follow them on this journey
into the cloud and for many people
especially those that comfortable with
the familiarity of doing it the old way
they're gonna ask why and you want this
team to be able to not only execute but
to also inspire the confidence in moving
to the cloud and so when you kind of
combine that with you know clear goals
and really go to understand what you
have in place today I just think it's an
enterprise up for success talking about
innovations and easy to use technologies
is good
but also brings up great powers great
responsibilities right
so how does gdpr and those kind of
regulations ensure they're working with
informatica because one thing is to be
GDP are ready and another thing to be
GDP are compliant absolutely you know so
how do you deal with that well you know
again I mean it's you know I don't want
like a broken record but yeah because we
deliver a platform that integrates you
know integration governance security but
a data management discovery as part of
the whole platform it's a little bit
easier for us to deliver on the
realization of being GDR PR compliant
not just ready you know for example you
know the right to be forgotten it's a
difficult problem right I mean if you
think like a global enterprise with many
subsidiaries probably not PII sitting
all over the globe right managed by many
different business units but the right
to be forgotten doesn't care about such
silos it's like compelling to be
forgotten and that's it you need to
forget me and so you know we have a
product called secured source that
allows a compliance officer to kind of
log in and actually says you know show
me all the locations within my
enterprise where PII exists and then
from there again it's like okay I have a
roadmap of where I need to go so that
when somebody chooses to be forgotten
I'm not guessing or hoping I'm able to
know right and it's definitely one of
the benefits of having that you know
unified platform that's you know
integrated as a complete solution
because it enables that and you know
things like GDP are and CCPA I mean they
codified much of what we've talked about
right we could talk about security and
governance
see'em since we began a conversation
short while ago and you know this kind
of like codifies the requirements but I
think in some sense every Enterprise
worries about this regardless of the
regulation speaking of things like
personally identifiable information and
other potential high risk sort of
information storage do you have best
practices or things that people should
be aware of when looking at that kind of
data that could potentially be high risk
absolutely so I mean we started off
talking about modernizing your data
infrastructure to bigquery so what's
from the construct of you know that
journey right and yeah we talked about
you know setting goals and building a
team to be successful well part of being
successful also is quick wins right yeah
you want to build a momentum based off
of success so you know one of the things
that I've seen successful companies do
is when they start their migrations into
the cloud let's not start off with the
tables full of PII because that
radically complicates the scenario
because now you guys get your IT people
in Baguio it's just security people in
barber governs people about so sometimes
it's best to know where your PII data is
not right and so by using your data
catalog by using informatica as
enterprise data catalog you can see
right and not guess it's like okay this
tables got a bunch of PII a lot of value
here but you know what let's do that
maybe in phase two or phase three let's
come and take a look at these other data
objects that has a lot of business value
below PII and that's gonna let me to
migrate to bigquery rapidly get success
build a new use case and now I can
repeat and build on that success and
gain momentum probably like almost like
the opposite answer of what you were
expecting but sometimes knowing where
your PII is not is very beneficial
awesome all right cool so we're coming
up on time here unfortunately but before
we go bill is there anything that we've
missed or you wanna mention or make sure
that you get out there so people can
hear it you know mark so number one
thanks to you Gavin have a great time my
chat with you both yeah I would say that
to our customers listening today you
know check out the partnership between
our companies it's fantastic and I truly
enjoy working with the team at Google
and together we're doing some great
solutions for our customers and it's fun
to be in market with you guys so thank
you awesome well thanks for being a
wonderful partner well bill thank you so
much for joining us today on the podcast
my pleasure thank you huge thanks to
Bill for joining Gabby and I this week
super interesting episode really I don't
do a lot with big data analytics so it
was super handy for me to learn more
about that that area and some of the
migration patterns that people have plus
I feel like if you do some more in that
area then you can add that to your title
this year yeah then I can have a long
title like Bill well more relevant to I
think everyone
listening than your title I think we
have our question of the week yes yes we
do go ahead ask it I'm ready so when you
create an app engine app you get a
domain that comes with it yep
usually a pretty generic domain based on
the project name and then you know App
Engine but of course you can use your
own custom domains yep and I think a lot
of people you know they want to do that
because custom domains are nice yep but
when you're using a custom domain
sometimes a lot of times you need to use
subdomains yep how the heck do you use
subdomains with a custom domain in App
Engine
oof that's a good question so there's
actually a lot of really cool ways you
can configure subdomains with App Engine
in both static and dynamic ways which is
super nice so for a static point of view
you can set up dispatch yamo it's a
configuration file wherein you can
configure actually a variety of stuff
not only just subdomains but also pods
and some other things to particular
services so services are individual
deployments inside App Engine like if
you had different API endpoints you
might want to do different services and
you can have versions within those
services as well so you can set that up
within your dispatch amol to say like oh
I want you know dog food up bar
I want that com to go to my default
service but you know cat dog food up are
I want to go to my cat service and
that's pretty straightforward it's just
just an animal file and it was pretty
easy to set up that being said if you
want to get dynamic with it which some
people - and we use it for for some
things it might be a bit easier you can
set that up with wild cards as well so
you can do that to the lower level down
in your dispatch animal but if you just
want to do it simply you don't even need
a dispatch Gemmell you can set up your
custom domain with basically a wild card
so you might be like start free calm and
you can set that up in your custom
domain configuration and potentially
also have a wild card for your SSL if
you have an SSL which you probably
should and what's nice there is what
will happen there is if a person goes to
a subdomain writes a wild card could be
any subdomain App Engine will actually
look for a version or a service that
matches the same name as that subdomain
if you go to dog food com it'll go look
for a service named Doug and it will
then serve that so that can be a really
handy way of if you have some
to come up on a regular basis maybe you
have snapshots of documentation that you
want to be have version something like
that
that come up every regular period you
can set up something dynamic like that
so the all you have to do is create a
new either version or service that
matches this subdomain that you have and
then that will get served and if App
Engine can't find that subdomain we'll
just send it back to default which is
fine too so you can do some really nice
done it make stuff that way too so you
have lots of options so if you have the
wild card you obviously get all the
subdomains you want and then from there
you can either statically configure them
saying which ones you want or you can do
it dynamically and then pull up
different versions which I think you
made a great use case for when you said
hey you know you might have different
versions that are in the past and you
want to still have references to those
yeah so you kind of have two great ways
to continue hosting content all from a
single app engine project yeah and it's
kind of like that whole thing wins
convention for configuration you know
one way with the wild cards or you can
have static configuration using your
dispatch ammo awesome well I think that
should help a lot of people who are
looking to kind of make more complex App
Engine deployments awesome well before
we wrap up Marc are you going anywhere
doing any cool content are you working
on anything you can talk about it
there's a whole super-secret I'm always
nervous about talking about content
before it goes live because like what if
the dates change or anything like that
so it's super secret it's nothing secret
but you know they involve customers and
different people working with the clouds
yeah I'm like oh hey we got you know
next President Obama on here to talk
about cloud and of course I didn't but
that would be cool that would be really
cool so anything you recently released
that you can talk about yeah I mean I
think we released two episodes earlier
this month on snapchat which I think we
mentioned once or twice before which is
kind of our customer interview yep
series and I'm working on and one of
them talks a lot about anthos and I
think that's really timely just because
there's been a lot of buzz around anthos
absolutely and a little bit of confusion
about like you know hey what actually is
it and how does it work and I think this
helps talk a little bit about how this
company arctic found the use case for it
and then used anthos to solve it and I
think we're seeing a lot of cool media
on anthos there's actually a really fun
video that Sandeep just put out which is
a rewind of a presentation that next
called meet anthos and these rewinds are
fun because they only take about four or
five minutes to watch and they kind of
summarize that talk so I definitely
recommend checking out the anthos
episode the interview with arctic of
stack chat as well
as sandeep to meet anthos I guess it's
not really related to me traveling
though so long story short no I'm not
traveling because we're making videos no
no that's fine it's all good what about
yourself I will be took your next
presenting I'm pretty excited about I
always loved going to Japan and then the
day before the North American open
source summit there's an open source of
gaming day where are we presenting a
couple of things I think actually I'm
doing at keynote which will be fun so
I'll be doing that and I'll also be
hanging around the North American or if
it's or summit so I'll be hanging out
there so if you're around come say hi
very very cool it sounds like dream in a
lot of places hi I get around a bit I
feel like for all the traveling you do I
don't do which is good because then the
mark equilibrium would be upset if we
both travel the way people both didn't
travel Yeah right some kind of paradox
yeah you can't have us both at the same
place at the same time well I think I
think so so mark thank you so much for
joining me on this week's podcast thank
you mark thank you all for listening and
we'll see you all next week bye
[Music]
you